all right here we go we are having
another I am NOT a ma another
celebration another streaming thing
animals today I'm a since we did one
yesterday today we're celebrating having
reached but not actually completely
passed a milestone in video production
I've created 500 videos in the core
concept series that I think many of you
have watched at one time or another
should probably actually come up with a
badge for some for people who actually
read all five watch all 500 of them
maybe two badge is one for people who
watch all of them the other for people
who not only watch all of them but read
all the texts in any case I thought what
I would do is before taking you know
questions and comments I already see
some on the side that I'll get to in a
bit is talked a bit about how I got
started with with shooting this
particular kind of video since it's been
a number of years and where I'm planning
on going with it and I also want to
mention too that I created something
that I don't usually do i created a poll
that all of you who are participating in
this can take if you want to if you
click on the little eye thing up in the
should be top right corner you'll not
only see the usual patreon thing and
also a link to the core concepts
playlist but also the poll I'm asking
people I'm gonna keep shooting these
these videos where do you want the the
focus to be ancient medieval early
modern 19th century or 20th 21st century
so I'll see what would people have to
say about that
so I see a lot of stuff coming in here a
lot of people are saying congratulations
that's very nice of you
and you know I'll say something as well
this is not something that I think I
would have sustained were it not for
devoted subscriber
and supporters and fans people generally
like these videos I do get some you know
nasty or other types of comments as well
but for the most part it's been it's
been a very positive experience and you
know that's that's important I think I
was just answering a question on Quora
today about YouTube stuff and you know
it was by somebody who I think was quite
understandably worried about people
attacking his or her stuff when they put
that out there and if you look at a lot
of YouTube comments there they're often
quite quite negative right so let me
explain how I got started with this so
originally when I was shooting YouTube
videos it was just me coming in I wonder
if I still have it here I've got the
tripod I mean I mean digging in my my
one of my many drawers well you'll just
have to imagine I don't think I have any
of the cameras still here I used to use
a flip camera and I would just put it on
this this tripod you know and come into
class and and plop it down and just
start lecturing and you know hopefully
the students wouldn't walk in front of
it or bump it or anything like that I
wasn't using any recording device like I
I use now here you can see my little
lapel mic that of course you see how
more recent videos and then I record the
things on here and take that sound file
it was just me setting this this tripod
up with my old flip cam and shooting and
I did that for entire class sessions and
we didn't do any real editing at all
just took the things and plunked him up
there and had some descriptions didn't
worry about metadata any of that that
sort of business because they were
primarily for my students as a resource
if they missed class many of them were
athletes and he had to travel or they
were in the band or things like that and
you know they would still go to class
and then people from all over the world
started chiming in and saying oh this is
really helpful for me my instructor
won't explain anything I don't know how
many comments I got like that people
saying my instructor
talks down to me won't answer questions
you know it's really quite sad in many
ways and so the stuff started catching
on and I was shooting these these you
know videos were like 50 minutes to up
to an hour to half and contrary to all
the experts who are saying at that time
you know videos for pedagogy can't be
any longer than 10 minutes you know
because the experts don't actually know
what the hell they're talking about much
of the time people would watch them all
the way through but then I started
thinking you know I'd look at the the
shorter videos and I was thinking can I
use any of these as resources for my
students and I'm not going to name any
names but all of you you know you've
probably looked at a lot of things on
YouTube and you see these you know two
to ten minute animations with lots of
glitz and lots of production and music
and they're often kind of short on
substance and sometimes they're actually
wrong because the people are are more
interested in making videos and less in
making particularly good videos so I
started thinking to myself what can I do
for my students that would be you know
not that these these marathon class
sessions but you know more like the
videos that I'm seeing coming out where
it's one one main idea like say plato's
doctrine of the forms you know in this
particular piece or Aristotle's
distinction between three different
kinds of friendship so I started
experimenting first with taking class
sessions and which I already shot a long
video now is teaching ethics and intro
for like you know the third fourth time
at Marist and I I already had video
footage I was like well now I can shoot
but I'm going to turn these into these
shorter videos and that's what that's
what I did well that was really quite
helpful and the students responded well
to it and people were like yeah I kind
of like this stuff so then I started
doing it outside of class and then we
got this this chalkboard right which
many of you have seen at our old place
in Kingston New York where I had like
the bookshelf behind and you know this
is of course at my studio in Milwaukee
where we've lived since 2015 and you
know as I've been teaching classes
whether they're my own online classes
I did some work with a few educational
startups none of which ever went
anywhere with a player now and in the
global Center for Advanced Studies
unfortunately neither of them panned out
and I also started creating my own
classes in teachable you know the study
with Sadler Academy but I also started
teaching you know it you know for other
places here in Milwaukee and then I
would say well you know it'd be nice to
have some videos on say des cartes
discourse on method because I'm going to
teach that you know and it'd be cool to
have that as a resource for my students
and I've got other people would like it
as well so I started shooting those
sorts of things and that's what I've
been doing continually on you notice
that a good bit of the video production
is in fact driven by whatever I happen
to be teaching that that semester and I
also shot some stuff that I thought you
know kind of needed to be out there like
the paschal stuff I got commissioned to
shoot some some of the videos like
somebody for example said hey I want you
to do heidegger's discussion of Plato's
you know allegory of the cave and so I
said okay I'll do that for a price and
you know we agreed to a price and then I
shot it and uploaded it and it was not
only to benefit that person but but
others as well and so now the core
concept series you know we've reached
500 of them and I'm thinking about what
it is that I want to do going forward
and I think you know I still want to use
them for my classes so I'll you know for
example I'm going to teach an
existentialism class this summer it's an
online class so I need some more core
concept videos on existentialist
thinkers right but I also want to start
filling in gaps where I where I think
well this is an important set of ideas
or this is an important thinker and
there's not a lot of really good quality
content out there it's like you know
very long videos on the one hand or the
short glitzy high production low content
videos on the other hand there's not a
lot of stuff in between so I want to do
some more
of those so for example you're going to
see within the next year you're
definitely going to see some stuff on on
well you will see it actually because
I'm teaching it this semester David Hume
and the the inquiry regarding human
understanding because I need that for my
students but also because we need to
fill in those those gaps I'm not
teaching Locke this this term and I
probably won't be teaching him next term
either but it would be kind of good to
have some stuff on like primary and
secondary qualities or the the theory of
property that that's in the second
treatise or you know some of those key
key ideas as well alright so that's
that's probably enough of me talking ant
you about what we're doing again you
know thanks for showing up everybody for
this celebration I'm really kind of
excited and happy about about that and
it's not just because I'm getting over
being sick and now starting to feel a
bit better so I have more energy
actually enough energy to shoot videos
tonight I haven't shot videos for over a
week but all yeah share this this time
with you again let me remind you those
of you who've popped in recently we have
a poll if you click on the little I
button you'll see that poll I'm gonna
take some you know some suggestions
limited suggestions of course because
it's a poll from from all of you as to
what you'd most like to see coming next
whether it's ancient medieval early
modern or 19th century or 20th century
philosophy so let me start looking now
at what we got here okay
so Peter says I just discovered your
channel today I have to say your
lectures on the Apollonian Dionysian
dialectic are brilliant so that must be
the Nietzsche of birth of tragedy stuff
I've got four hours of those four
lectures and yeah and the Apollonian and
Dionysian that's just the beginning all
right there's a third important noble
response to life that's the plants both
of them in in Nietzsche's view and
that's the Socratic Alexandrian response
as well so
glad that you like that chef Ali Khan
can you suggest some ways to develop
kids interest in philosophy there's a
number of ways I mean part of it is is I
think modeling this doesn't just go for
philosophy this goes for for literature
and literacy in general one thing that
psychologists have discovered by doing
you know longer term studies is a good
predictor for whether a child is going
to read on their own outside of you know
whatever they're required to do for
school or later on for work but for
pleasure is that they see adults and
adults who they care about deliberately
structuring their lives so as to read
for pleasure so you know if you grow up
in a house without any books or the only
books there are textbooks and whatever
you happen to be bringing in probably
not going to be a reader right if you
see mom and dad only reading the you
know things because they have to not
because they actually like to probably
not going to be a reader so I would say
that that's a really important baseline
right there just the you know modeling
taking an interest in things and you
know there's a lot of ways to take
philosophical concepts of one form or
another and make them relevant to
children one way is thinking about
practical life and moral dilemmas that
they run into about fairness or what
they ought to do and a friend is getting
in trouble or you know how they how they
understand their emotions philosophers
at least you know interesting
philosophers have a lot to say about
those topics and kids are also
interested in the nature of reality and
how we know things they're interested in
metaphysics and epistemology and you can
also build off of what they're doing in
school you know hopefully without
undermining the teachers that they have
because odds are the teachers are not
super well versed and anything having to
do with philosophy so you don't want to
like have your kid come home from Earth
science class and then say well your
teacher completely you know
misrepresented the scientific method
here's you know Karl um Karl Popper or
something like that you know you want to
build off of what you what there
getting I think there's many many
opportunities for having kids encounter
philosophy and I think it's important
too that when you're bringing in an idea
say from Aristotle you let them know
that it's actually they are an Aristotle
it's not like they're gonna pick up the
nikah McKean ethics at age 10 and start
reading their way through it but you
know if they hear it enough right maybe
then later on they'll they'll start
finding their way to it or when they
take a college class or something and
encounter it then you've got something
to work with they're not just
encountering it for the first time so
it's a great question I see some hellos
and some congratulations here there's my
congratulations on the big 500 keep up
the good work I will certainly try to do
that made of clay five five hundred our
AMA well it's not five hundred hours
five hundred videos these are at the
hour yes you know I don't know how many
hours of video I actually have I I don't
know if it's a thousand yet because a
lot of what I've shattered these core
concept videos right so there aren't
quite so many of those those are you
know they're not quite as long they're
anywhere from ten to thirty minutes
all right so more Marko's 500 CLOB
congratulations hope they have another
500 I would like you know this is rather
ambitious and we should probably think
about how this could actually happen I
would like to you know maybe make 5,000
I mean I'm definitely gonna make another
500 because there's so many gaps to get
to I mean you can just take any any text
any great text and philosophy and if
it's you know there's gonna be quite a
few core concept videos we could we
could get out of it when now that I have
actually got a better idea about how I'm
doing it as well
I think I was kind of you know less
certain about how to divide things up
when I first started but you know so
fine if I did 5,000 right so if I did
250 a year then that's pretty ambitious
let's say I'd do 200
how long would that take me well 10
years would be 2020 years would be you
know for 4000 and then another you know
2 3 years after that so you know 22 and
a half years now you know everything
would be wiped by then if I still have
there but you know I wonder who knows
our YouTube hole look like this and -
all right we may be in a totally
different format but you know it sure
couldn't hurt to keep cranking them out
so that's that's what I plan on undoing
all right here's some other questions
that are not about that but about other
things there's vias if I can publish the
translation of Patri a Omani take and
hard to find anything about it it's a
little-known Maurice Blondell work
maurice Blondell is a little known but
you know undeservedly so French Catholic
philosopher from the late 19th century
early 20th century on whom I wrote my
dissertation somebody who's who's really
you know at the heart along with
birdsong and and a few others in in
producing the revitalization of
metaphysics in French thought in the
20th century paved the way for
phenomenology as Christian du Pont is
shown in his dissertation so yeah I mean
what I've got when I translated it I
translated it into English and the file
is somewhere in my stuff in a
WordPerfect version so I would have to
convert it to Word and then take a look
at what I actually translated it might
not be that good I don't know I haven't
looked at it for years and years and
years the translation so before I
publish it I definitely want to like
read it through again and probably
improve the the grammar at that time I
had the view that a translation should
really sound like a like a translation
it should be as close to the original
text as possible I don't actually
subscribe to that quite so rigorously
originally anymore so I think I would
probably want to change it a bit arty
Whitby
can you explain the rivalry between
Diogenes the cynic and played-out did
they really hate each other so this is
this is stuff that's coming from you
know hearsay much later on from Diogenes
Laertes did they hate each other I don't
know that they hated each other
they certainly espouse different ways of
living you know Diogenes there's some
you know disagreement about whether
Diogenes really studied with the
anticipation at you know with should
Diogenes be considered the first cynic I
don't really buy it I think that the
antis Tamizh who's studying with
socrates lineage really is you know how
we got the cynics cool but Diogenes is
definitely attracted to it by
temperament cuz I think many people are
too philosophical schools you know
certainly at certain stages in their
life Diogenes and Plato stood for two
very different ways of doing philosophy
and they both like razzing each other so
you know I I think that that's that's
all we need to explain that rivalry
memento mori' says congratulations I
hope your health as well and you're
happy hope everything's all right yeah
my health could be better you know I've
gotten nailed by a few illnesses sort of
seasonal things you know colds and flus
maybe a bit more this time around and
and you know it keeps me of course from
going to the gym and working out but you
know hopefully this week I get to go
back to the gym and you know I'm in the
process of losing weight and eating
healthier and all that sort of stuff and
if I exercise the way I should maybe I
can live for for quite a long time
apparently you know genetically looks
like my biological parents alright you
know given me some some decent stuff to
work with so yeah the key is to not like
accuse to reduce stress I think all
right more congratulations from
different people I'm not going to go
into the Jordan Peterson thing that I
keep getting asked about every single
time so you know maybe maybe someday
I'll find
time to do a video about that all right
smack lover 69 saw your Heidegger stuff
recently really great thanks oh good I'm
glad you enjoyed it
you know III do want to shoot some more
Heidegger core concepts stuff and you
know maybe some other stuff as well in
that existentialism series if I ever get
that that rolling again those longer
hour long videos on existentialism
Heidegger is a you know an important
philosophy made some contributions you
know use become even more controversial
lately with the publication of the
plaque notebooks now we know that you
know there really is no like well he was
only kind of a Nazi thing to say about
him he really was a Nazi but you can you
can strip away some of the ideas from
that I mean he's a brilliant interpreter
of many thinkers so it's kind of
unfortunate all right marca will there
be more Nietzsche yes there will
definitely be more Nietzsche and
hopefully I'll get to it later this
spring because I am teaching a little
not the whole thing but some parts of
Beyond Good and Evil to my my students
in the Marquette foundations a
philosophy class and we're doing a
really short bit of Nietzsche for the
MATC intro to philosophy class here as
well so you know probably some stuff
from from that I mean down the line
you're definitely going to see some
stuff from the genealogy from birth of
tragedy probably do some stuff from the
spoke zarathustra cuz people are out
there certain like key passages that
people are always you know going back to
what does this mean what does this mean
so yeah we'll do more Nietzsche Rohan
what normative ethical system do you
adhere to one I'm a virtue ethicist I
think a lot of people know that I'm
rather eclectic I draw upon as with
Cicero you know for example somebody who
I hold in high esteem I draw upon you
know the Stoics pretty heavily the
Aristotelian tradition pretty heavily
good bit of stuff from the platon
aspartic you lay the middle plate missed
some Christian thinkers you know I think
it's important to engage with the
insights that the existentialist had and
you know Alistair McIntyre is somebody
in the who's still alive you know
hopefully for quite a while longer who I
really look up to and take is sort of a
you know example of what a good virtue
ethicist look looks like not only in in
personal life but also in how he
approaches other traditions alright five
five five three two seven asks a
question a lot of people I think
probably don't know that I am a big
metalhead and not only you know listen
to heavy metal and not only sort of was
was raised on that and still go to
concerts but also have a blog which I
haven't contributed to for elect I'm
called heavy metal philosopher so and I
do have the intention doing writing in
there eventually and he has favorite or
she I don't know what gender they our
favorite Sabbath album yeah that's a
tough one
I you know I'll say this so some of this
has to do with a bit more biography if I
could only like pick one thing from
classic Sabbath I would probably take
that compilation album we sold our soul
for rock and roll because that's got
some of the really great stuff
throughout there Causey time that you
know the original lineup career in it
doesn't it I mean there's a lot of
really great albums in that that set but
that's kind of a good one I also you
know when I was in high school I got my
hands on born-again and a lot of people
don't like that album it's the the
production on it could have been better
the album cover is terrible but you know
Sabbath with Ian Gillan pretty awesome
you know and Tony Iommi and geezer
butler we're really on top of things as
far as
Griff's you know one of the heaviest
metal riffs ever probably something that
if I ever get get to come on stage to
you know some music I would probably
want to do is from zero the hero I
really love that that song then again
you know one of the other super heavy
riffs is from the the one sign well not
one sign one of the songs with Ronnie
James Dio singing the devil cried pretty
pretty amazing stuff but so I would you
know if I could only pick one single
album probably would actually pick one
with the do albums because I kind of
like do better with Sabbath and I like
the revitalization that he brought to it
then I like Ozzy so I guess the mob
rules alright
RJ R T with me what are some of the
biggest misconceptions about ancient
philosophy that's a good question I
would say probably the biggest
misconception is that you know and a lot
of people have this because they come to
it you know anticipating it to be like
contemporary philosophy that it was
disconnected from life it was a sort of
abstract thing that people were doing
and it was just for these very small
elites and that's not really the case
you know it's not as if everybody was
studying philosophy but ancient
philosophy was meant to be something
that you would you would live out and
you know sort of think your way through
so I think that's that's quite important
dude's vying says ten minutes is the max
for super boring content I guess that's
going back to that thing with the you
know pedagogical experts even today
still you know I'm developing this
online class and you know some of the
people that I'm working with they're
like don't make your videos any longer
than ten minutes and I'm like you just
don't don't get it you know that that
was maybe decent advice a long time ago
but it wasn't even decent advice then
because it is based on the sort of
average
level of college lecture which is you
know not very good but if you're
engaging your audience if you love you
know like goods you know stories and
examples and your your energetic and you
know you're not you're not just
presenting yourself in a boring kind of
way I think you can you could I mean I
have no problem without notes sometimes
giving talks that lasts over an hour and
people are not leaving the room and
they're they're engaged and sometimes
they want to come up afterwards and talk
more about it so a lot of it has to do
with you know being able to reach a new
audience I'll say something here too
that that's another thing about ancient
philosophy you know we we often get this
impression that what comes from Plato
that
well there's philosophy and then there's
rhetoric and you don't want to be
involved in the rhetorics you know and
the Sophists and stuff like that and
Aristotle his own student is like yeah
that's a mistake
you know you need rhetoric that's why
you know I'm giving you this book the
art of rhetoric and then Cicero much
later on he he busts the chops of the
Epicureans and the Stoics saying you
know you guys have interesting material
but you're not attentive to your
audience you should actually learn how
to arrange your stuff so you can reach a
fuller audience it's important to
actually be attentive to the people that
you're talking to all right it's kind of
common sense isn't it you want people to
listen to what you have to say you think
that you know the stuff that you're
talking about is important
make it a make it something that people
can bear listening to so all right let's
see here five five three two seven how
much con should you read and understand
before trying to read Hegel oh you know
some it'd be a good idea to probably
read your way through the prolegomena
and the groundwork and maybe some some
of the other stuff but you know it
depends on what Hegel you reading to by
the way I don't even suggest starting
with the phenomenology you know I didn't
the half hour Hegel thing on the
phenomenology precisely because that's
where most people start but I I think
it's actually better to start with the
lectures on the history of philosophy
and the lectures on the philosophy of
history
those are more accessible works so
alright mark I asked more core concepts
of Nietzsche yep gonna do some of those
any possibility to have marks yes that
can Stein yes Foucault yes Derrida yes I
don't know when I'll be doing those yeah
I do need to get some Vic and Stein
stuff done for my MATC intro to
philosophy class but you know we'll see
what is probably just going to be some
stuff out of philosophical
investigations and I don't know how much
I'll actually be able to do Marx you
know I got to decide what I'd actually
work on buco and Derrida again the
challenge is to figure out what I would
want to start with those those guys are
complicated all right Artie would be
which ancient philosophers do you think
are the most underappreciated that's a
good question
I'll say Plutarch a lot of people know
Plutarch because of his biographies
right the parallel lives but Plutarch
himself you know he wrote well he wrote
all these different works and they're
called the moralia it's not one work
it's sort of like the Bible right you
know Bible biblia means books whole
bunch of different books different kinds
of points of view and interests so
Cicero has all this stuff crammed
together into the moralia and there's
some really cool stuff in there I
actually like him quite a bit what other
ancient philosophers are under
appreciated I mean you can't say the
Stoics because they're getting a lot of
attention now hmm I mean Cicero still I
I think you know a lot of people are
like Cicero is just a derivative you
know he's taking ideas from other people
and putting him together and giving his
own little you know take on it but his
take isn't very interesting I think
that's that you know
let's show somebody who doesn't actually
read the text attentively they or they
came to it just with a that sort of
thing in mind I really like
I think he's still kind of undervalued
stocks so to speak he's worth reading
for his own you know sake he's worth
reading because he made this major
contribution to the history of
philosophy and he's worth reading in
order to be able to figure out what the
Epicureans and Stoics actually did talk
because he's closer to them in time than
some of the other sources that we have
and he tells you know tells us what
their doctrines were I think that he's
pretty accurate in that and then I mean
the neoplatonist SKUs ertainly use more
study Alexander of Aphrodisias great
person to read as well if you're
interested in the Aristotelian tradition
so you're usually just scholars who
check him out but I think he's kind of
kind of you know like readable at least
so he's worth checking out yeah those
are those are some of them I'd also say
too you know because they're in that
still in the ancient period some of the
early Christian philosophers you know
that they get written off oh they're
just they're their church fathers or
theologians locked on seus is a
philosopher you know he's got this
amazing book on the divine anger where
he really contributes to the discussions
about what anger is he knows the other
philosophical schools and then
contributes his own interesting view not
only about divine but about human anger
Justin Martyr is worth reading clement
of alexandria is i'm a big fan of him
you know so there's quite a few but John
Cassian too right
there's quite a few people that are that
are worth checking out within that time
all right so oops just skipped up a
little bit 1916 had a thing hearing I've
registered her here although you're all
my property now okay then
Ranas is busting his chops as well all
right and certain cyclical Greg could
you maybe do a core concept video on
speculative realism Garcia Harmon
Mazzilli oh well I mean there's a thing
I don't do two core concepts on a sort
of given broad movement because that's
not a core concept
I would have to do like a series on any
one of them and maybe I will but I mean
they're not high on my priority list
that's the sort of thing I would do if
commissioned but there's so many things
within the history of philosophy that I
really need to to get to alright let's
see here made of clay what's my thoughts
on Matthew 10:39 whoever finds their
life will lose it whoever loses their
life for my sake will find it
considering that people usually find
their life in Christ first I wouldn't
make too much depend in a sort of proof
texting way and then drawing you know
like conclusions from it in that sort of
way from any particular verse they're
always having to be read in a larger
context Cynthia says a second the
request for Vic condition I'm struggling
with attract hottest big-time yeah I
mean and the track taught us could
probably dealt with in not too many
videos because you know it's pretty you
know there's once you see what's going
on there there's not that much different
things going on so RJ Whitby why is
skepticism less popular than the
philosophies of Platonism Aristotelian
and stoicism I don't know that it is I
see a lot of people calling themselves
pyro Nyan skeptics or academic skeptics
today there's a whole skeptic movement
and they do often you know reference the
ancient thinkers I would say that
there's probably you know the stoicism
is probably the biggest ancient
philosophy that that's being given a
sort of modern update and I would say
that epicureanism and skepticism are
probably in second and third and then
Platonism the Aristotelian ISM would be
coming behind there's probably more
interest in Aristotelian ism among
religious people than there is among
secular people using it as a way of
orienting their their lives
Goldman like my discussion of Seneca is
on anger glad to read that Cynthia says
congratulations thanks for making
philosophy relevant and understandable
finish the short courses on the Apollo
you know at Italia absolutely brilliant
I'm glad you you you enjoyed those I'm
gonna be building online courses that
include like handouts and stuff like
that in the study with Sadler reason IO
Academy and they have over in teachable
Bill Austin would you recommend some
epistemologists sure Descartes Pascal
Hume Locke I mean these are all people
doing major work in epistemology if
you're act if you're asking about like
contemporary epistemologists by I don't
have any idea that's not it's not
something I work in alright
intellectual dark web 500 hours of core
concept videos makes it sound like there
isn't really a core at all well again
it's not 500 hours of core concept
videos I don't know where people got
that idea if you're actually watching
them you know of course that they're
anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes so each
one is a core concept it's not saying
that there's some sort of vast core that
they're all part of all right cyclical
says 5 million videos that would take a
team you know then I would have to do
what they call on business scaling up
that'd be a tough thing to do right
because I'd have to trust whoever is
making the videos to do them in you know
a long I don't want to say you know in
my way but along the lines that I could
get behind and that'd be tough to do
right okay let's see here Elvis
Presley's do you think compatibilism is
[ __ ] no I'm a compatible list okay
it'd be weird if I thought it was right
so what you know compatibilism is
somebody who thinks that there is a
causal nexus and there is determinism
and yet there is freedom and then the
trick is to explain how that all that
comes about and the people who I like
the best are compatible lists as well
marcos Corona is Donald Trump the reason
why Socrates didn't like the idea of
democracy so obviously you can't you
can't mean you know that Socrates
somehow presently saw ahead to this time
and
assualt Trump but you're asking like our
figures like like Donald Trump and what
he does and represents why Socrates
didn't like the idea of democracy you
know in part but you know you can't have
a Trump without having people who vote
for Trump and you can't have a Trump
without you know corrupt political
parties not not excusing the guy he's a
total dumpster fire as far as I'm
concerned but both both as a politician
as and as a human being but you can't
have somebody like that actually making
it through you know threading all these
needles without some major rock within
the the political body and that's what
we've had and you know yeah Socrates was
worried about demagoguery and he's
worried about that you know that sort of
thing
but you know it's not like he thought
that oligarchy was going to be any
better so you can say the same thing
about Aristotle - all right Jonathan
says have you determined what text you
will work through after you finish the
half of our Hagel series if so is it a
secret I have a not to you know
determine what I'm going to do what big
book I'm going to do I have said I'm
going to apply the half hour Hegel sort
of methodology to other texts and I've
done that with like Epictetus --is and
karidian 21 videos you know going
through the entire text same sort of
thing reading it aloud commenting on
each each chapter each verse you know I
want to do de cartes meditations I have
a nice copy over on my shelf that has
the Latin and the French and so I'll
probably put that you know Latin French
and English there and then comment on it
you know bit by bit
I'll probably do an Psalms Proust loggia
as well so I've you know I've got those
sort of things but what what big book
right I mean I thought about doing
heidegger's being in time or starts
being in nothingness people want me to
do Hegel science of logic but man that
would you know I'm not a hick alien to
begin with so you know taking on the the
task of doing the phenomenology is
already
a labor of love and yeah III you know I
think doing the science of logic would
probably kill me
I don't know there-there's other there's
other texts that I might be willing to
do you know I've thought about doing
like Aristotle's metaphysics some people
want me to do Thomas Aquinas is somewhat
LOV I but then I'd probably you know die
before I actually finish it there's so
much material there well you know I
don't actually know anybody who's read
the entire soma
anybody who says that they have I
usually assume they're lying or that
they skimmed chap there's sections of it
it's so I I don't know I don't know
we'll see I would have step Nate who are
some thinkers you've yet to do any core
concept videos on to plan to wink wink
Hobbes yeah Thomas Hobbes is definitely
somebody I need to shoot some some
videos on and I've promised to do that
and passed and haven't gotten to it so I
should should get to him he's important
yeah
all right now I'm just guy will it be
any content about Herbert Marcuse ax
perhaps something about one-dimensional
man that's not a bad idea I like that
book mark ooza is not that hard to
present on in my experience so you know
the easier it is to present on it the
more I'm usually willing to take on work
having learned the hard way about that
sort of thing yeah more cuza he'd be
somebody fun to do I'll mention this too
by the way one of the reasons why I did
the existentialism series and why I
started hampire Hegel is I would get all
these people like in the first two years
of my shooting the videos saying can you
do videos on this can you do videos on
this so eventually I created a poll for
all my YouTube subscribers and I was
like okay pick anybody you like who
would you like me to do videos on pick
like your top three of people and the
top four
way more than anybody else were
Heidegger Sartre Hegel and Marcos oh
there was a lot of interest in him back
then I was really surprised you know
because I he's somebody who I've read
and I known a few people who like him
but I haven't read too many I haven't
seen too many other people who actually
reference him
and so yeah he could be a good person to
do one dimensional man I think would be
the place to start and then maybe eros
and what eros and civilization there's
there's other stuff and I've already got
them all right bill I'll said nothing
like philosophy and metal and then
there's lying well there's also dark
wave I don't know dark wave and I think
must be like some new wave thing maybe I
listened to some of that and so Nielson
Enter the Void pretty much started do
metal masters of reality well I mean
Witchfinder general I would say along
with Black Sabbath started do metal
it's unfortunate Witchfinder general
didn't stay together much longer because
their stuff is amazing
all right Gabriel who we have more metal
stuff power metal and philosophy sounds
like a wild night in the humanities
Department yeah but I mean most most of
my colleagues don't like metal
you know I then I sometimes play it when
I'm sitting in my office and then I get
weird looks you know I have an office
over at Marquette that I share with two
other adjuncts all right let's see here
five five five three two 70s how do you
feel about Horkheimer and Adorno
dialectic enlightenment and were the
culture industry yeah you know if I was
if I was gonna try to do core concept
videos on Adorno it would probably make
more sense to do it you know in his
collaborations with Horkheimer because
they're a hell of a lot easier to
summarize d'Arnaud is very tough Adorno
is Hagel level difficulty - straight at
what system of ethics are you most fond
of well I brought this up before virtue
ethics you know
five five five three two seven it can be
difficult to reconcile liking popular
music especially jazz door no hated jazz
with Adorno's ideas well there's nothing
that says you have to accept all of his
ideas right he could have been wrong and
quite a few things cyclical what
tradition do I draw my ontology from
should one's ontology be as flat as
possible so am i again you know same
thing is with with ethics I draw from
multiple traditions I'm an eclectic and
should your ontology be as flat as
possible
your ontology should be as rich as
possible so that you can actually take
into account this incredibly complex
world that we we live in you know I'm
not I'm not in favor of making
philosophy nice and simple so that
problems are easier to solve because
they're not usually then solved you know
philosophy is a way for us to one
discipline among many that helps us sort
of figure out where the hell we are and
what to do you know for me philosophy is
ultimately practically driven even if it
is speculative or theoretical I'm with
Hegel on a mat quite frankly so bill
says congratulations on five hundred
videos what books do you recommend to
develop a proper understanding of
Christian history and theology well I
mean there's a lot of Christian thinkers
that I think you you want to read that
we're really you know important and you
know you can read summaries of them but
it's it's it's good to actually read
them too and I'm a big fan of some of
the early church fathers I mentioned
some of them earlier in this like if you
want to understand monasticism for
example you you really need to read the
Western monasticism Benedict's rule
right and then one of the books that he
mentions to the monks that they ought to
be reading John Kaos Ian's conferences
and you should read the Institute's as
well yeah and you know again
like for Western Christian Augustine is
absolutely central you know for the East
I mean there's all these great church
church fathers and doctors but then you
also want to read the fill of kaalia a
lot of interesting thinkers crammed in
there as well and there's a lot of good
summaries out there I'm also a fan of
you know the people who do sort of like
the cultural studies I was just moving
books around in my my shelf you know I
was thinking about like it was looking
at Wayne Meeks the origins of Christian
morality and thinking okay can I put
this over by the Stoics because he
brings up the Stoics or should I
actually you know put this back on on
the the shelf back with the Christian
early Christianity stuff so yeah I mean
that I think that's that's kind of good
and then you know you want to read other
authors along the way as as things are
developing if you want to understand you
know like how the Protestant Reformation
came about for example you know you
should renew her and his stuff back and
forth with Erasmus and some of his uh
his treatises are good to read and you
know you won't understand like where
other traditions came from
denominationally definitionally you got
to actually like check out some of the
people so like you want to understand
where the Methodists and Wesleyan xand
and holiness people are coming from read
John Wesley you know I think it's always
good to check out the primary sources
all right let's see here Noah says odd
I guess should I read keep reading Kern
yep why not
I guess Carnap is getting kind of
revival these days who would ever
thought right a logical positivist would
kind of interesting thoughts on Deleuze
and then to vani us how much of you
interacted with Deleuze I like you know
some of Deleuze and stuff I myself like
the stuff that he did with guitar II
less than I like when he's doing his own
thing my favorite stuff by him is the
logic of sense and essays critical and
clinical I think that's the writing
translation of it but you know you also
get it like you know he also does some
interesting history and philosophy and
then so that's really what the logic of
sense is too by the way but you're
always getting more to lose than you are
the actual person that he's writing
about and so yeah all right
no I also nice well I cover live Nets
what about the analytics such as Carnap
Quine Russell and Neurath well I did in
the analytic just recently James
Rachel's but yeah you know I'm not I
guess I could do Quine I always find him
really boring quite frankly error you
know is is a bit more fun I wanted to
shoot some stuff on air earlier this
semester but didn't get to it because
you know I was talking about a motive
ISM I mean if I'm doing that I should do
Charles Stevens Stephenson's him Russell
yeah I'll probably do some Russell down
the line in carnea live minutes yeah I
definitely can of core concept videos
and I would probably start with the
discourse on metaphysics with live nuts
maybe put it together at the Monod ology
which is sort of a best hits list or
slogans list and then then you know
start looking at some of his other
essays I don't know if I'd take on the
theodicy well that's a big book alright
let's see what else we got here you got
a scroll up a bit it just skipped again
Oh dudes vibe do you know a good work to
get an overview for the Chinese
philosophers
like for example in the history or
something like that um I think the stuff
that I read is probably kind of out of
date there's probably better stuff you
know let's come out more recently but I
do like that book by Gram dispute errs
of the Dow it's it's I think it's pretty
good some people say that it's not but I
think it's pretty good and you know I
there's this book and I've got it on my
shelf and I think it's called the source
book in Chinese philosophy it's about
like this thick and it's an anthology
and it's nice it's got a lot of stuff
all the way up to like the 20th century
but again I'm not you see this is one of
the things when it comes to Chinese
India and even Islamic stuff I'm not I
don't know the level of expertise that I
have in Western philosophy you know all
right let's see here in cyclical any
up-and-coming philosophers we should
take a look at I'm sure there's a ton of
them but I don't know any I'm you know
that's it's kind of funny I'm kind of
Lovecraftian in that way I'm an
antiquarian right as he used to call it
right and so I don't know enough about
my my own president I mean I don't have
any any friends or colleagues that I I
would you know unequivocally say oh my
gosh they you have to read this person
[Music]
there's a lot of great thinkers out
there we're living in kind of an
extraordinary time I mean I will say I'm
really looking forward to seeing Chris
gills book coming out on stoicism and
virtue ethics and if you haven't read is
the you know recent book on self and
Hellenistic philosophy you probably want
to check him out that's Chris gill at
Exeter University nice guy kind of you
know fun to meet him because I hold his
you know work up in high esteem I've
been fortunate gotten to meet quite a
few of my heroes over the course of time
you know Julia Anna's you know Kate
Rogers Alastair McIntyre you know it's
pretty fun Paul Griffiths when I get to
it when I get to do that and most of
them turn out to be really cool people
which is nice all right
Magnus official my heart broke when I
heard about your black dog Magnus as a
heavy metal philosopher have you heard
Cradle of Filth album idiot it begins
with songs at the gates of Midian
Cthulhu dawn I think you know I heard
some Cradle of Filth years ago I didn't
like what
heard I'm not into like newer stuff for
the most part but yeah Magnus says he
was a great dog
I really here's my little buddy so now
macaroons macaroons asked me about
something I'm not competent to talk
about either what painters do you feel
had the strongest philosophical impact I
don't know that's that's a great
question
but I don't I don't know chip asks do
you teach on the pre-socratics do you
plan on doing any core concepts on them
I do teach the pre-socratics when I have
to it we're handicapped by the fact that
we don't really have much original stuff
right we have these summaries you know
and I actually I mean I talked about
that in my Aristotle core concept videos
on metaphysics book one because
Aristotle's talking about them but you
know I think we can need to make a
distinction between actually having like
texts or fragments of texts and then
having some philosophers take you know I
mean Plato tells us what the
pre-socratics thought as well but it's
within the context of Plato's project so
you know like I could see doing
something on Parmenides and his poem and
I could do I could see doing something
on Heraclitus but you know it's it's
which fragments do we take that you know
it's kind of tough right to figure out
what we're gonna do Gabriel asks what
are your feelings on Berkeley that's the
guy you know and the the he was a bishop
in the Anglican Church he sort of midway
between Locke and Hume in the the
empiricist lineage I like Berkeley I
enjoy reading him I actually try to do
some writing on him a long time ago it's
probably in a format that can't be read
by my computer anymore because I wanted
to publish some stuff on Berkeley some
time ago but never got to it I mean
somebody who I've taught and I enjoy him
so you know I can see doing some core
concepts on him I can ask did the exist
Angeles Heidegger's
Simone de Beauvoir Camus who have any
opinions criticisms on the competing
analytic school of their time says from
the Vienna circle that constrain Russell
so they didn't know anything about MIT
kim Stein and I doubt many of them even
like paying any attention to Russell the
the Anna circle would have been more
like Heidegger's you know view because
they you know they were saying his his
stuff was nonsense I mean they if they
thought of the with the analytics were
doing in general is just being a variety
of positivism not even logical positive
just kind of like oh well here's what we
reduced philosophy to analytic
philosophy and existentialism you could
say in broad speaking are you know
reacting against a certain kind of
hegelian ISM but sometimes incorporating
things from it there are some
interesting people on the analytic side
and then on the later I mean if you want
to consider a record existentialist I
don't actually myself but he certainly
took analytic philosophy seriously and
John wisdom the analytic side certainly
took existentialism seriously you know
so you know there's some some bridges
all right to Vaughn asks how familiar
are you with Negara Negara Stanny not at
all
I don't know Antarctic and could you do
who Cyril videos or is the outside of
what you prefer to cover well I could do
host role videos I find who s role
incredibly boring to read I'll just
admit that right off the bat and I
actually did my master's thesis on oral
I did it on the past of synthesis
lectures but you know if I guess if I
was going to do something on West Road
probably beyond like Cartesian
meditations cuz that's kind of
interesting stuff but and I find his
phenomenological descriptions kind of
dull you know
well you know another phenomenologist
i'd really like to do some stuff on his
mock Schaller and you know i'd also do
stuff on merleau-ponty he'd be fun to do
stuff on but I like reading them
I even find you know quite often this
will show a little prejudice on my part
I find Horrell scholars are usually
quite boring people if they're straight
out of us real scholars but that's just
my thing you know maybe it's a
personality type of thing
Anton Neil said I'm currently an
undergraduate philosophy student
considering pursuing medicine therapy as
a profession after how does having a
philosophy background benefit of
practicing clinician well that really
depends does it not on what you're what
you're studying if you're doing just
like analytic philosophy you know
reading like you know five articles
about this little thing here you know
using modal realism or you know talking
about internal ism and in you know
action theory or something like that
probably not much if you're reading
Descartes and Princess Elizabeth and
their correspondence about the you know
connection between the mind and the body
and you're thinking about that probably
quite a bit but not necessarily directly
it really depends on what you're what
you're studying and what you do with it
you know so that's probably a function
or factor of where you're going to
school one of the problems with
philosophy is it's not like we have a
standard curriculum that's it's
literally all over the map you know I
get Marquette where I'm teaching this
this foundations class we don't even
have a common reading for that class we
just have a mandate gotta have some
Plato or Aristotle gotta have some
Catholic think you're got to have some
non-western or you know thinker and you
got to have some contemporary thinker
and they don't tell you what
contemporary means so I like mused Han
or Arendt for mine so yeah all right to
move on thoughts on geo trauma don't
know what that is so I don't have any
thoughts on it chip does playing metal
in your office regard and more resulted
more stew
showing up to your office hours very few
students have Destructo office hours
mostly just around midterms and final
you know it's not like students are
wandering the halls and then suddenly
hear metal and they're like where's that
where's that sound coming from I better
go check it out you know and many of
them I suppose would would you know kind
of you know they they it might be turned
off from that day it could be like that
that doesn't sound very you know
welcoming of course maybe they'd show up
and they'd be like I'm ready to party
I'd earned your song and and the singer
was saying are you ready to party I'm
ready to you know I'm blank again the
kiss like ah damn it
Oh anyway had a good joke there but now
I lost it all right I wouldn't step mate
what level of patreon support will it
take you to get to live out of a wine
jar well I would have to do it part-time
because I have a wife and you know kids
and a pet well two pets you know and my
books and stuff like that so it would
have to be like something that I would
do like part-time I think it'd be a hell
of a lot because that doesn't seem very
comfortable at all and here in Milwaukee
man it gets cold and then in the summer
it gets really hot so I don't know about
that Carlos is sociology integral with
philosophy more than psychology it
depends I mean psychology sociology all
the social sciences same sort of deals
with philosophy all over the map I mean
some places sociology is essentially you
know learning the stats modeling's doing
a few studies and then just like
crunching the numbers and then coming to
some conclusions in other places you'd
actually actually gonna study Mark's
favorite Durkheim other places they're
like marks whoo-hoo Weber you know so
it's really tough to say it really
depends on on the place
so can I be levy what are the chances
we'll see a half hour sublet a logia
when you're done with Hegel man that
would be a huge undertaking that would
that would that would be tough to pull
off
I'll do more core concept videos on
Thomas but I can't promise a half hour
Summa
because you know that would take a long
time
Kieran what are your thoughts on Sam
Harris not impressed I don't pay much
attention to him Adam you have to name
the king of philosophy you have to pick
only one time in epochs don't matter
well what would a king be doing I I
don't know if I had to pick a king one
person to make King well you know maybe
I'd pick Cicero right he was a good
judge of the philosophers of his time he
was pretty fair to them sometimes a
little tougher on the Epicureans maybe
that he should have been but so maybe I
do him
Jacqueline Chan have you ever met Iris
Murdoch no on that wouldn't she would
have been somebody I would have probably
greatly enjoyed meeting but but no I
never I never met her she has somebody
whose novels I much enjoy and I like
reading her for other stuff as well
she's a great philosopher Saku are zaman
what do I think of putting his response
to skepticism most people are
disappointed by it my experience I
haven't read Putnam for years he was big
stuff when I was in grad school even he
came and talked but you know I didn't
spend enough time on him to to really
understand Lucas asked one of my
thoughts on see Ron haven't read him so
I've read about him but I don't have
enough to say about him a retro gamer I
keep hearing modern popular literary
analytic philosophers refer to Ben you
mean figuratively do you know Ben you
mean is the philosopher worth in the
exposition or not yeah he's he's you
know he's mostly known for that essay
art in the age of mechanical
reproduction
Walter bending mean he left a lot of
stuff behind I've never found him that
profound or or great the way that people
who really get into him do seem to think
but maybe I'm missing something couldn't
hurt to read them make your own decision
about it but I've never you know I've
never found in measuring up to the hype
Kyle asks is there an identifiable
clutch moment where my intellectual
conviction is crossed over into some
kind of faith proper or is the struggle
and doubt intrinsic to the process faith
as in belief in God or intellectual
convictions crossed over to some kind of
faith I mean even people who have faith
have doubted sometimes Augustine is a
great example of that and you know
Maurice Bono
had this really nice metaphor he you
know he was involved in these Christian
philosophy debates there's a lot of well
where's you know philosophy and theology
began or something you know philosophy
and religion and he said man you you
know people won't want to have it be a
border like with guards on one side or
the other it's more like that gases that
inter you know penetrate each other and
their interest Isis there probably is I
mean you can definitely say well this
person's on this side this person is on
this side but you know conversion is is
not usually a matter of like one single
thing making a decision for you you know
determining you so I don't know if
there's there's an identifiable
threshold like that Jared what language
that's not English would you recommend
learning for abundance of material from
philosophers who wrote in that language
well great question so you know ancient
Greek
Latin you know Latin opens up not only
the Roman philosophers for you but the
Middle Ages and if you want to read de
cartes meditations in the original which
he wrote in Latin and it's principles of
philosophy French of course German is
good to have you know for other there's
quite a lot of stuff out there in
Spanish and Italian and then we could
talk about other languages I mean I wish
I knew Arabic but I don't so that cuts
me off from all of these you know
interesting Islamic and even some some
you know other philosophers who wrote in
Arabic you know Chinese Sanskrit poly
you know all of these sort of classical
languages in which there's massive
bodies of literature it would be good to
have so alright five five three two
seven do I know anything about the
philosophy department oh uh no I don't
oh yeah here we go rock and roll all
night and party every day I was blanking
on that for some reason I wanted to say
party every day and then I couldn't
remember what came after it well because
there's nothing that comes after it it's
before it all right
macaroons macaroons what are your
thoughts on the Aleister Crowley and do
you consider thinkers that could be
considered a cultist to be any value or
relevance to philosophy I mean they're
usually kind of marginal in part because
they want to make reference so much to
the occult but it could be interesting
to take a look at I had a student who
was constantly trying to get me to read
Crowley when I was teaching in the prism
and I just never actually found the time
but so I can't really say I will say
that it you know he did give us an
awesome
Ozzie song so it shipped you plan to do
any Duns Scotus videos I mean maybe
but he's not like high on the priority
list
Anton as a nephew to my follow-up I did
it for you in the other sense to my last
question my school is known for
bioethics so I guess that would help
yeah yeah
that's good do you think philosophy
majors still demonstrate skills he lost
or limited in other areas to study yes
one of the things that philosophers turn
out to wound up being quite good at is
making distinctions and that's not
something easy to teach right but and
not all philosophy programs necessarily
foster that but it is something quite
good and why is that
not the case or why is it not the case
for others they just it's not theirs I
guess they're usually so fixated I'm
like let's get through this material
that they they they're not as critical
in their their approach to it all right
Western man I'm thinking of entering a
philosophical undergraduate course next
year
I'm also very right-wing being
influenced by Ebola went on Spengler and
Heidegger how do i navigate leftist
marxist professors well I mean first of
all don't assume that your mark that
your professors are marxist don't
identify leftist with marxist because
they're not the same thing you know I
would I would keep your your your stuff
yourself because even among you know a
lot of people I mean none of these are
hiding or as a first-rate philosopher
none of these other people are and and
if you if you like them basically
because they fit the mood that you're in
yeah I mean substitute Nietzsche for
Spangler to begin with right substitutes
you know the classical French
traditionalists for going on and then
they weren't first-rate thinkers either
you know and maybe people will pay more
attention to it but and you know most of
the people you're gonna meet are gonna
are probably gonna be kind of leftist
but you want to learn how to
differentiate between them because
they're not all on the same page you
know think of yourself as having to
learn another language so alright James
oh corn what was the name of the guy who
studied Schopenhauer with well I took a
class with them I studied Schopenhauer
before
that that was Schirrmacher at European
graduate school he was a head of the
school at the time and what Wolfgang
Schirrmacher
and he was also the president of the
International Schopenhauer Association
or Society really interesting
interpretation of him I kind of liked
him all right Arvid what do you think of
Dawkins striper in Europe I like Dokken
striper in Europe don't really like him
at all and even Dakin is is getting on
the light side for my taste
you know another band that kind of fits
in there but it's got a bit more gritty
that I really really like it that
something sometimes people are surprised
by his rat but I wasn't really into what
I called metal light or what people
nowadays call hair metal I'm more into
you know what we call traditional heavy
metals so you know the bands that I I
really enjoy would be like in 70s you
got you know the classic three of you
know Black Sabbath deep purple and Uriah
Heep and then you get Montrose coming in
and Judas Priest
and Motorhead Hawkwind I also like and
then you know we get like this
burgeoning in in the late 70s early 80s
oh I really love them
scorpions except Iron Maiden tank Raven
sax and you know in in the states you
know we got kiss we got we got a twisted
sister in in the New York area and riot
just in New Jersey then in LA we've got
you know the Nexus of Motley Crue rat
Quiet Riot wasp you know sort of
American metal Lizzie bored and this is
all kind of heavy stuff right and then
you know we also have of course a few
other bands in in there that I have left
out
but you know though that's the kind of
stuff that I was really into Dakin was
kind of kind of on the white side for me
I could I could get into it you know
back in the day I pray actually I didn't
see them in concert at Monsters of Rock
years ago and they were good but then
they had George Lynch you know so I
don't know about that now all right
five five three to seven the dude
cosplay two core concepts video for
April Fool's please well now if I did it
that would kind of give it away wouldn't
it but actually that's not a bad idea I
don't I don't know about like is a core
concept video but it's not a bad idea
I actually I'll tell you I did think
about for April Fool's and I never did
this I thought about like you know doing
one of those videos or I'd be like well
it's been a good run really have enjoyed
making all these videos but I'm too busy
now I'm gonna close up shop you know and
then get to the end and say April Fool's
but I never did that subconscious qualms
if you read anything from David Foster
Wallace if you have what do you think of
his work I've read a few essays I'm not
a big fan
I don't understand what the the buzz is
about so yeah Robert what's your
favorite movie I haven't seen it for
years but I will still say that my
favorite movie is the dualists which is
a Ridley Scott movie early on with David
Carradine a Peter carrot yeah David
Carradine and and Harvey Keitel as the
main characters beautifully done
beautiful sound score great swordplay in
it classic story yeah so that that's
good Ken says it seems Heidegger was a
serious Catholic growing up yet still
continued to read a lot of Catholic
theology you leave the faith due to more
philosophical reasons or something else
yeah I think he left it behind say the
same thing with mock Schaller right they
were both going to be the great Catholic
philosopher for Germany they both ended
up leaving it behind
probably some of it had to do at the you
know there's always some some crazy
[ __ ] going on with the church
hierarchy anytime you you look at the
church is always in need of reformation
from within and often doesn't get it and
I think Heidegger you know with
Heidegger and and with Schaller there's
also intellectual reasons why they they
left that behind but but they thought
that it you know it's still mattered and
why would you stop reading Catholic
thinkers just because you aren't going
to church aren't a Catholic right
there's still important thinkers right
Mubeen are you a physicalist or a
dualist are you somewhere in the middle
like non reductive physicalist not
something i think about very often i
guess you could say that you know I'm
probably more dualist than than than
physicalist or monist materialist right
in that I don't think that everything is
reducible to simply you know
configurations a matter whatever else
there's gonna be but yeah it's not
something I devote a ton of thought yeah
quite frankly Arvind what are some good
books on forgiveness and redemption how
bad can a person be before they've lost
all hope of redeeming themselves good
books that's that's tough I mean there's
there's a literature out there on it but
it's not something that I do a lot of
research on so I don't have any great
suggestions for you about that how bad
could a person be before they've lost
all hope of redeeming themselves dead I
mean there's always some hope but you
know if you only have a little bit of
time and if redemption has to do not
just with like saying that you feel like
you're wrong or something but actually
doing a lot of work to like fix things
both within yourself and and in all the
stuff that you screwed up maybe there's
some practical considerations about that
as well
Adam is there a phenomenon of
consciousness in Heidegger's philosophy
if not what does he replace it with them
I'm not sure what what a phenomenon of
conscious
this means a concept of consciousness I
mean the whole thing is phenomenology is
about being conscious right so and
consciousness of things so I'm not sure
what what what's being asked Kyle says I
know you're a stickler for catch-all
terms do you think something like meta
modernism may be a harbinger for future
discourse practices I don't know I've
never heard never heard that phrase meta
modernism I don't I don't know what it
means
so edom and if someone's gonna get a
bachelor's in philosophy what do they
recommend they focus on do you think
logic would be most beneficial I'd focus
on taking all your classes you know
taking a wide range of stuff if you want
to study just logic study just logic see
how far that gets you
you know you're missing out on some
stuff then but it's you know you can
certainly make progress with it I did a
lot of work on logic because I was a
philosophy and mathematics major got
enough to like get out on the other side
and realize that not everything could be
reduced to it so or even to language or
something like that
Adam are you planning to write or
publish your magnum opus
I would first have to have a magnum opus
I've nowhere near that point there's a
lot of things I want to write and
publish a lot of books I want to write
and not a single one of them is a magnum
opus they're mostly things like you know
on other thinkers or you know I'd like
to revisit the Christian philosophy
debates some of what I'd like to do is
popularizing things for people making
you know like taking the Aristotelian
virtues and saying how do you how do you
actually live these out in life today I
want to write a book you know on
end-of-life decisions for pet owners you
know there's a lot of things I want to
do but none of them are what I would
consider my magnum opus and I'm not sure
there's a magnum opus in me
and I you know I don't think there has
to be necessarily not all of us are
designed to
right the next you know you know
meditations on First Philosophy or the
phenomenology of spirit or life of the
mind or something like that so Dora can
I please make more videos on the con
maybe a Lacan for dummies series you
know if I could do some videos on the
con it's a matter again finding the time
right that's always the tricky thing for
me because I you know I've got to work
to earn a living right
I had a life and you know got one kid
about to go off to college so I do a lot
of teaching and I do a lot of various
types of work and I you know do a lot of
public speaking and things like that so
it's a matter of making the time I like
looking at quite a bit all right Dylan
to what degree will I understand Hegel's
logic by reading the shorter logic
versus the larger logic I started to
read the phenomenology of spirit PDG but
it seems I should at least read the
shorter logic to really flush it out I
mean they're all different books they're
all different works right you're not
going to find much connection between
the encyclopedia logic and the science
of logic and they're really designed to
do two very different things I guess so
yeah that's about it that's the retro
gamer concepts versus injunctions do you
give credibility to a cognitive
dissonance encountered and being asked
to explore scholars couched in a
religious tradition who against
supplication and instruction give
credibility to a cognitive dissonance
encountered when being asked to explore
scholars couched in a religious
tradition against supplication and
instruction not quite sure what all that
means I'm you know I'm the
a person that I don't have to buy into
somebody's religion to take seriously
the framework of concepts and
experiences and meanings that that are
important for them in their community in
understanding what it is that they're
doing I can put myself imaginatively
into their place you know so for example
I'm not a Buddhist but I can understand
the difference between Zen and Pure Land
Buddhism and why they're you know I had
so many odds on so many different things
over things that they take very
seriously so yeah I think it's all I
have to see on that Jason what's my
thoughts on Beyond Good and Evil
I like Nietzsche a lot you know I I draw
quite a bit on him I think he's pretty
pretty interesting so it's a great book
all right let's see here
skipped up a bit or skipped down a bit
Anton
why are the existentialist more Camus
Nietzsche so popular and widely regarded
today is it because their ideas are
inherently more relatable to a general
audience or is it something more I mean
I don't think that they're more popular
and widely regarded today existentialism
is probably more popular in the like 50s
through 80s than it is at present but
I'll say this about existentialism so I
you know I got into it quite a bit as a
kid I mean Nietzsche and Kierkegaard
with people I was reading and really
enjoying and so was Camus back when I
was in undergraduate and I went through
a massive Nietzsche phase in graduate
school that was tied in with other
things going on to kind of elitism and
focus on the body and you know lots of
sort of through monic stuff and then you
know what I what I was getting out of it
when I was when I was younger it was
it's real stuff that those are real
themes and these thinkers but then when
I returned to it in my 40s and started
you know rereading and rethinking
there's so much more stuff there there's
there's some you know some really great
thought involved across the
existentialist spectrum there's a lot of
kind of undervalued stock you know I've
mentioned left chest off many times or
taking a gas that is somebody worth
reading Miguel de Unamuno really worth
reading as well you know there's all
sorts of thinkers who who we could bring
out and adapt to modern life and you
know the existentialist they may not
have had like say cell phones but they
were thinking about other stuff that had
to do with day to day living so that's
important all right let's see here the
mall something I'm sorry if this
question offends you I swear I'm not
trying to corner humiliate you I'm
really curious about the ask with all
respect as a knower of the history of
thought how can you have faith and be a
Christian at the same time no all the
other beliefs that ended up transforming
into Christianity because they don't
have an exclusive is viewpoint where
it's like well we've got this little box
here and this little box here I have no
problem saying that so Astron ism gave
Christianity through Judaism its
conception of hell you know I think
that's really cool hell is a fiery place
that is right it's not a problem
I think the only time that people really
have problems with that is when they are
very very rigid and that's so artificial
you know it's it's almost like they're
more into a set of ideas than they are
the real lived experience I mean I I've
known as Oh ass trans I was lucky enough
to have one as a nice teacher when I was
in undergrad jewett and you know you
compare notes about things and and
you're on the same page about a lot of
things you know if you want to if you
want to call it you know the judgment
one thing or the judgment another thing
I don't really have a problem with that
and if I wind up you know making it
through through some you know miracle or
through grace or something like that
into heaven and it turns out that you
know oh Jesus wasn't a God himself and
you know say the Muslims had it right he
was a prophet you think I'm a [ __ ] and
whine
when I'm up there I mean I'd be an idiot
to do so right so you know it's uh and
I'll tell you how did I come back to not
just Christianity but the Catholic
Church which is you know it was filled
with all sorts of problems by the way
but is at every point in its history
he's reading and so it read his letters
as they're reading people in the day
that I actually respected like Anselm
and Aquinas and Chester kid and seeing
that they weren't dummies and that they
so quite often you know the picture was
better from where they stood then then
just standing outside and saying no I'm
not gonna go in there you know and you
can go in and go out zero-nine Rickson
what are your thoughts on merrill apone
teach here's from Canada I like Marilyn
Polti I've tried writing on it before
never really successfully I like his
phenomenology of perception you know
he's somebody who I used to read a lot
more often don't do it quite so often
anymore retro gamer john paul ii his
degree dissertation was on mock Schaller
surely as written work stands more than
the course of their lives yeah I mean
that's one reason to read Schaller I
guess I mean you can also read Schaller
because he was great
he's a great phenomenologist and
sociologists of knowledge and has some
really brilliant insights about the
human condition and you know history and
things like that but if you know the
fact that john paul ii wrote his
dissertation on Schaller is what you
know gets you into it then great a
favorite poet and poems you know
probably Rilke I'm really big on him I
like as a poet but I also like you know
the letters that he wrote the novels and
things like that
Kanaga Livy Aquinas is compendium of
theology as a few sections on sin no
idea what a compendium of theology is do
you mean the Summa theologia if so that
it doesn't have a few sections on soon
there's a whole bunch of them
but maybe the compendium is like some
best hits list that somebody's put
together
gabriel sutherland going off a previous
question some of my own experience how
do you feel about the common hand waving
of idealism or non-physical monism that
happens in education and other places
well I think everybody's doing hand
waving to the very bottom I mean I think
materialists are and matrix as well if
we're gonna get quite you know honest
about these these sorts of things I
think that you know we're we're all
doing the best we can to figure out what
the hell is going on and where we are
and how to make it a little bit better
and and that sort of stuff alright mr.
big weak knee would you ever do a video
on loving us sure yeah he's one of the
few altruistic phenomenologist again you
want to read Schaller right so be unique
to hear my thoughts on him yeah loving
us is cool I got a lot of levy nos when
I was in graduate school I actually
studied with a guy who was one of the
original translators of lemme nasus
before he took his his name off the work
because he had a you know sort of
argument with his mentor at the time
about how to translate things but I got
turned off by lebanon's because they're
always like oh you're facing the face of
the other you know they bring up all
these tropes you're doing you're doing
Theory therefore you're engaging in
hypocrisy and you're facing the other
and all this stuff and after a while you
get like first off that's not loving us
we read some of his other stuff second
you know you're all a drag to hang
around with all right Gabriel asks
the two choices that are often presented
or physicalism or dualism instead of
presenting all three options who says
there's only three you know where people
are like ISM versus ISM versus ISM it
was a struggle to like figure out why we
have to frame it that way to begin with
you know that's not how it was framed in
the long tradition of philosophy right
we if we can't fit the the great
thinkers that we want to talk about
within these narrow boxes those boxes
are at fault that's the problem there
all right let's see
Arvid heidegger's association with
Nazism is a bigger problem for a rents
legacy than it is for his own agree or
disagree totally disagree why the hell
would that be a problem for a rent she
was with hiding her when she was quite
young she didn't you know she almost
died under the Nazis right
she writes I mean one of her great works
is the origins of totalitarianism she's
definitely not pro-nazi so I don't know
where that would be coming from all
right I mean if to draw to a close I
have to do a lot of grading
unfortunately midterms macaroons
macaroons the modern political right
seems to become somewhat attached to
Nietzsche what's your opinion on this
and what do you think the right
accurately embodies within Nietzsche's
philosophy I mean that was a that was an
issue back in the day - it's not a
absolutely new thing I think most people
who talk about Nietzsche don't know what
the hell they're talking about whether
they're on the left or the right or the
center because Nietzsche is a hard
thinker and there's a lot going on a lot
of moving parts to his philosophy right
I know that that many people on the
right who I've interacted with Nietzsche
would consider them you know basically
filled with Rosanne to mount and subject
to their own herd mentality they all
like to think of themselves as like you
know the the new dimension right but
they're not I mean let's be honest about
that so that's really I mean I think
that's sort of the damning thing you
know would need to look at them and say
oh you know yeah
seen your type before and it is a type
and it's not the highest or we need to
consider them to be some some great
whatever you want to consider it retro
gamer says have a nice lunch thank you
very much that's it's very nice of you
and I will although he right now it's
it's actually going towards dinner time
so maybe I'll do that tomorrow it's you
know we're we leap we left we left ahead
because I always get it mixed up is
daylight saving time over or are we in
daylight savings time now I think
daylight savings time is over and and so
it's now 533 so it's time for me to
figure out what I'm what I'm going to
cook so alright let's let's see what
else I can take very quickly Oh Lou how
do you stay so driven I find it amazing
how much you understand and comprehend
well I always feel like I'm not getting
enough done and a lot of it I think is
you know the years and years of
developing habits and so you get a kind
of inertia that that that carries you
through which is cool when you've got
habits established as far as what I
understand and comprehend you know I've
been studying philosophy in an academic
way since I was 20 20 years old and I
had studied you know bits and pieces of
it before because I wanted to understand
things I can't say that the Nietzsche
that I read or the Camus that I read
when I was you know like in high school
I actually did understand very much of
it but I was I was trying right and you
know I never I never although I do
specialize in something I never just
wanted to remain specialized just in one
area I always wanted to keep reading and
reading and reading and seeing what
other people had to say so that that's
part of it and I was fortunate to wind
up when I was in school at places where
it was pluralistic so no one group
dominated so I didn't buy into the like
prestige of oh you got to do philosophy
this way or else here you're no good
right the way I think a lot of
impressionable young graduate students
do and then I never bought into the
prestige of whatever it is it's you know
the latest trend at the Ivy League
because I knew that they were no
different than the rest of us
and so that was was helpful I think all
right let me see if there's something
else I can quickly knock out to do
alright there is one that I
okay so here's a good one to sign off on
and let me remind you to before we end
the session if you haven't voted in the
poll about you know what you look most
like to see in the core concept videos
going forward ancient medieval early
modern 19th century 20th 21st century
make sure to vote in that poll and click
the little I button and then it'll be
the second thing down there so Ken asks
I know you've just mentioned that a big
postural fan what do you think of the
story of his students like Edith Stein
literally risking their life by
smuggling his work in Nazi occupied
countries well I think that's very cool
right and the horse Royal archives that
low even are they exist there precisely
because of that and there was a lot of
it and he wasn't the only person whose
archives were smuggled like that again
mock Schaller mocks Frings carried
around the Schaller archives in a bunch
of suitcases for years and years and
years right I think it was Maria
Schaller had originally secret in them
away and then Frings got his hands on
them that's all you know very important
stuff right and we can think of a you
know even getting people out of out of
these countries again bring up Hana
Arendt she she barely escaped the
concentration camps herself Edith Stein
was not so lucky and yeah this is this
is all quite important it doesn't change
anything about his role himself and the
the you know interest or dullness of his
phenomenological descriptions and a lot
of it again has to do with temperament
we don't all have to like the same
philosophers it's not I don't say that
host role is not not an important
philosopher or he's not a great
philosopher I just don't find him
particularly interesting and since I
have limited time on my hands and maybe
gonna you know be lucky enough to live
another 30 to 40 years that's you know I
have to make decisions about where I put
my
time and and priorities so all right
I'm gonna sign off thanks to everybody
for joining me for this celebration 500
videos in hopefully another 500 videos
and more in the future God willing
and I'll see all of you in our next
event for the month long maybe I will
maybe I won't which will be one of our
philosophy pop-ups coming up everyone
say exactly one but it's coming up this
coming week and yeah have a great
afternoon
evening morning night whatever it
happens to be where you're signing in
from